we hadn't seen the president for more
than 36 hours
and it was clear for donald trump the
grievances still burn brightly
if you count the legal votes i easily
win
if you count the illegal votes they can
try to
steal the election from us
michigan we're way up in michigan it was
full of conspiracy theories devoid of
any evidence
and he even outright lied in georgia i
won by a lot
a lot with a lead of over
getting close to 300 000 votes on
election night
in georgia and by the way got whittled
down
and now it's getting to be to a point
where i'll go from winning by a lot
to perhaps being even down a little bit
the election apparatus in georgia is run
by democrats
georgia's election officials are
republicans
[Music]
contrast that to this his rival in a
short
focused maybe even presidential call for
calm and patience
we continue to feel senator and i we
continue to feel
very good about where things stand
we have no doubt that when the count is
finished senator harris and i will be
declared the winners
so i ask everyone to stay calm all
people to stay calm
the process is working the count is
being completed
and we'll know very soon
but across the country there are those
who are fighting donald trump's fight
and will be emboldened by his words
as the vote counting finally nears its
end so the possibility of a result
unlikely to soothe trump's anger as he
spoke at the white house
a photographer took this picture the
president has made it clear
he won't go quietly thank you very much
there is no greater insult in trump
world than loser
does this look like a man who thinks
he's winning
greg milam sky news wilmington in
delaware